[Musique]
on vient de l'apprendre hugo chavez a
succombé au cancer pour lequel il était
soigné depuis un an et demi nicolas
maduro son dauphin désigné avait déclaré
que son pays vivait ses heures les plus
difficiles
durcissant le ton il a accusé les
ennemis du venezuela d'être responsable
du cancer présidentielle deux
fonctionnaires américains ont été
expulsés hugo chavez était arrivé au
pouvoir en 1999
et il avait le génie du verbe et un sens
consommé du spectacle
hugo chavez ou l'itinéraire d'un
iconoclaste qui a révolutionné son pays
son enfance ressemble à celle de la
plupart des vénézuéliens ses parents
sont de modeste instituteur la maison
familiale ne dispose même pas de
l'électricité
l'armée représente une chance inespérée
pour ce jeune provinciale déshérités et
déjà passionné de politique
en 92 révolté par la misère qui sévit
dans un pays qui coule pourtant sous les
pétrodollars
le militaire tome de prendre le pouvoir
par les armes
le coup d'état échoue c'est par les
urnes qu'hugo chavez obtient sept ans
plus tard ce qu'ils convoitent le
pouvoir vous aimez briser les chaînes de
l'esclavagé
ces chaînes qui entravent le venezuela
et vous allez balayé ces politiciens
pourris
de la parole aux actes il établit la
république socialiste bolivarienne
hommage à son mentor simon bolivar le
héros de l'indépendance
éducation santé le robin des bois des
bidonvilles multiplie les programmes
sociaux en direction des plus modestes
en dix ans la pauvreté recule de moitié
tribun populaire il use et abuse de la
télévision alo presidente et c'est son
émission 6h02 tribune dominicale où
selon l'humeur il parle cuisine
politique ou congédié en direct des
collaborateurs
des patrons leur éventuelle un style qui
exaspère une politique que la
bourgeoisie exècre en avril demi de
l'opposition croit tenir sa revanche des
manifestations dégénèrent chavez est
destitué mais le putsch fait long feu
quarante huit heures plus tard il
retrouve son fauteuil washington qui
avaient cru se débarrasser du trublion
se retrouve dans le viseur george bush
ou l'incarnation du mal selon hugo
chavez
hier le diable est venu ici
[Musique]
exactement ici et ça sent encore le
souffle aujourd'hui
son anti impérialisme obsessionnel le
conduit cependant à nouer des amitiés
controversé avec le syrien bachar al
assad ou encore l'iranien mahmoud
ahmadinejad
mais son père spirituel son mentor en
politique c'est fidel castro la maladie
du dictateur cubain rapproche encore les
deux hommes les visites à la havane
s'enchaînent mais à partir de 2011 c'est
pour soigner son cancer il se rend sur
l'île la récidive a été fatal l'une des
pages les plus tourbillonnante de
l'histoire du venezuela se referme
[Musique]